former Republican congressman Newt
Gingrich was Speaker of the House
between 1995 and 99 including the time
when Bill Clinton was impeached he is
also an author and a former presidential
candidate he co-wrote the new book
collusion a novel it's about a former
Navy SEAL and an FBI agent trying to
stop an attempted Russian poison attack
against the United States mr. Gingrich
is in regular conduct contact with
President Trump and members of his
administration good morning welcome to
be with you alright you are here as a
former speaker and as a novelist so in
that sphere
in that spirit I would like you to
engage into in a bit of fantasy imagine
you are Nancy Pelosi and you get the 440
page mullah report what do you do oh I
think she's done exactly the right thing
I think again based on my experience it
on the Watergate experience if they can
find something which leads the American
people to favor impeachment and this is
one where I think we got out of sync we
we had a report from Ken Starr that said
Trump that Clinton was guilty on 11
counts know if Muller had reported the
Trump was guilty you'd be in a different
world but even in our case with with a
solid report guilty on 11 counts the
country ultimately listened to the
argument said no and the Senate refused
to convict well you have a Republican
Senate the odds against conviction are
overwhelming and I think speaker Pelosi
is trying to say to her House Democrats
you know you want to maximize the
political advantage you don't want to go
into an ambush where we look hyper
partisan and I'm not totally sure they
could pass impeachment because Democrats
elected in Trump districts may say you
know I'm I'm not quite there right now
president Trump has tweeted about the
Muller report since this reason I think
about 80 times including what our own
legal analyst Jonathan Turley said was
one instance where he essentially
contradicted what Don gann his his white
house counsel told Muller which said he
could that could actually put the
president in jeopardy does the president
get stopped talking about this and
tweeting about it probably not for a
while Trump's entire career starting
here in New York
it's the counterpunch I mean he lived on
you know page six the gossip columns and
he learned
you hit back and you hit back harder
than they hit you hit back longer than
they can hit and it's just in its who he
is and so I think he gets up in the
morning and something triggers the fact
that oh yeah I really am mad about this
and so he hits and doesn't matter that
he hits back with lies I mean the
Washington Post today England has the
Cussler who's kept track of this now the
president has surpassed 10,000 false or
misleading claims since becoming
president
well I find it hard to take anything the
Washington Post writes seriously they
hate Trump they hate Trump every day
their coverage is stunning but even
senator Mitt Romney who is a Republican
yes also dislikes Trump he's a
Republican just like someone and still
say so they're making false MIT Romney
said he was sickened at the extendin
pervasiveness of dishonesty and
misdirection by individuals in the
highest office including the president
yeah and I was a little saddened that
MIT couldn't ring himself to say he was
sickened by the Justice Department
basically having a coup d'etat he was
sickened by the Obama administration
trying to go after an American political
candidate there are lot of things we
sickened about in Washington DC and it
was sad that MIT could only find a
Republican to be second but it what can
you challenge about Mitt Romney's
character I'm not trying to tell
challenges character I'm challenging his
judgment when you say that you don't
trust the Washington Post but 10,000 as
they used to say about thousand Elvis
fans can't be wrong 10,000 the
numeration is not again people who don't
like Trump can't get over this all right
Trump is a businessman he has the he's
not a politician he's not trained by the
ways of Washington here's a tendency to
fling things around and I wouldn't get
up and say I'm gonna verify every single
thing he said that's not who he is let
me add on big things he has been
stunningly effective has he been sending
your book is about Russia and the real
threat of Russia a long-standing threat
that's a big thing as he has he
rhetorically been in terms of educating
a country partially what your book is
trying to do has he been on the beam as
far as you're concerned with respect I
think he's moved to tougher and tougher
sanctions I mean the irony is after all
the attacks on Trump Trump has been much
tougher than put than Obama was the
sanctions are much tougher and he
continues to
increase that including on the Russian
role in Venezuela why make Russia the
villain in your book because I think
it's important to say the American
people that Russian penetration of
American society I have a book coming
out in October on China the Russian
penetration of American society is real
and you know we had the highest-ranking
person in the FBI who's supposed to
catch spies in fact was a Russian spy
and I think people need to understand
this
well Muller said there's nothing with
the Trump campaign don't relax and think
that means there's nothing going on
Jared Kushner said the Russian influence
was really just a few a couple of
Facebook ads oh I think the Russian
effort to influence our elections was
was basically not very effective or
aggressive but that's not what the
Russians really work on the Russians
work on placing agents of influence like
Alger Hiss and putting them in positions
where they can have huge impact and as I
said if you have a 15 or 20 year period
where the top FBI agent is a Russian spy
the amount of damage they can do is
unbelievable and he clearly for example
turned over to the Russians a series of
American spies who executed all right
Newt Gingrich thank you for joining us
this morning and as we mentioned his new
book collusion goes on sale tomorrow we
thought there was no collision but there
is a collusion it's a book by Newt
Gingrich